かもよいいなんですけどホストファミリーを変えざるとアベニーくす cyber
world 年前か
靴下んでちょっとテンションの高いですから辛いずねこれはトイレなんですけど何から
ん
いくぞん
は
ん
何からそうかなーってないずは一応サブチャンネルデー
その引っ越すとばそうも言ったんですけど
メインでお話しておきます5を
服ヘアをかえって量に住もうとんですけど雷変だ3月まで人がいっぱい開かないって
くれたんだよ
待てないということで部屋だけ変えたんですよホームステイの
の帰るときにもうちょっとスタッフの人に全部 a
僕の炭は動画が取ることなんで
ちょっとうるさいうる酒できるじゃないですって言ったら
うーんんじゃねぇなんかなんてよ
なんかああなにクリエイティブな人たまでみたいなこと言われて
エアー
と言ったら
あいつはこう言う
5ホスト技だけの指輪済ませてもらってるんですけどすごいいいですね
そのホストラザード僕しかいないんだよなんて言ったの一対一でご飯2はすごいコミュ
ニケーションってきて
前の飯より確実にいう話してるんだよ
いいすねでもそのストラーダにも僕
北辺だ趣味があって自分で自分で自分の動画とるんですよって言ったらあの面白いコネ
みたいな感じで
別動画とる許可も得てるんでも暴れ放題です基本的にこの家ではパパ
あんまりなぁあまり打つ知っ
何枚こういう人6憂鬱なよくないと思うけどね増強把握ん
能力が
大事ということを彼学んでちょっといこうと思いますね nex 5 r もレンズ
食われたんでも現在が出す買ったでも
今使ってるのも nx 細胞なんでもうね
最強です字五番です
イギリスっぽいっしょ
ってパターンだねぇ
寺なポストマザーは仕事に行っててなんか仕事でたんまり家にいないんですよ
自分で決断してエアを支えたのは本当に正解だと思ってます竜盾ってなんか
プレッシャーなくていいと思うんですよ
日本語禁止とかそういう辛いじゃないですか僕の学校でも日本人たくさんいるして
ちょっと考えが変わって留学で
日本人とは絡まないとかそういうのってなんかもったいないと思うんで自由に行きます
せっかくの出会いの機会を札にしてる気がしてるんで
外人だけど弦の弦のもいいと思うんですけどやっぱ楽しいのは一番だなと思ったんで
英語だけしか肌されみたいな
自分追込み指揮の勉強法案でちょっと良くないと思う機構理事効率効率がありんと思う
んですよ僕にとってなければか
英語の勉強は大事ですけど
やっぱリリースを楽しむことが大事だと思います
に入ってこうわかんねえなとりあえず自分で部屋を支えたのはすごい良かったと思い
ますドアの a にいても頭が家族が多かったんで必ず家に大会いるんですよ
気使って動画を問えなかっただろうし人がを過ぎてご飯中もすごい
メッツところ中で話ってるね
自分の発言する機会がなくておやつ今ホストわざと積んでていった市田塚かなせてるん
でもしね帰れるようなことがあったら
現在我慢せずに
それを変えようってそれ使うマネー
大事だということも考えました結果的に
こういう感じで締めてるんで良いと思いは強い
あああああ
ん
じゃあ
最近グッ
ちょっと何かなじゃあな飽きてきたか